[Music]
welcome back to another awesome episode
of the careful boys where we're
extremely careful out here y'all
and we got another very very very fun
personal topic for you hopefully you can
relate at home we would like to discuss
today
how when we were young
our parents disciplined us
time out
was big
time before um
eight hours
honestly shut the [ __ ] up that's
solitary you're on timeout but you have
like all your [ __ ] playstations eight
hours in his room
timeout was you could play playstation
but there's no sound you can't
like damn
took away the phone now that we got
happy child life out of the way
if we could go back to the want to go
with the craziest punishment the
funniest one no we gotta warm up into
let's go sad laughs so everybody has
this a really bad taste in their mouth
at the end we've definitely heard a lot
about what happened to bart this has
been once bart got jacked up a lot bart
deserved it though it's different bart
had many big box stores
some furniture
[Laughter]
i think i told this story before but
when i was a kid
i was i'm six and seven years
younger than my older sisters so i was
in kindergarten and they were working on
some like fifth grade pro i don't know
playing some like elementary school
project take a [ __ ] on and uh they were
making they were taking plastic spoons
and they were turning them to snowballs
like snowmen sorry
and they were they had these little like
tiny little plush balls and i was in a
garden balls yeah little cotton balls
they were decorative and then i thought
it'd be funny if i put them on my nose
and like oh you get stuck up there i was
ripped dude i [ __ ] ripped it
everyone's busting up yeah dude kids are
[ __ ] dying in the aisles everyone's
[ __ ] yeah i was a comedic genius back
then i put the cotton balls up my nose
and i got stuck and i started freaking
out because i was in kindergarten
because i was a little [ __ ] dude i was
raised by women and i started crying
i couldn't get them out probably pretty
funny too because your nose a little
plugged up so
yeah yeah yeah and that's when i became
a [ __ ] mouth breather but then
you know i couldn't get him out my mom
freaking panicked she obviously got
scared pull him out because it was
really easy and then i think the one of
the first punish this is like probably
one of the first like corporal
punishments my mom made me do she made
me sit in the corner
like face the corner squat heels off the
ground and then just pull my [ __ ]
ears for like i don't know how long
like i became the birth of nick the year
that was one of why i was one of mine
and fitness too you're [ __ ] like
squat right and then you're [ __ ] like
this just squatting all the way down
dude high heel squats [ __ ]
nobody can see those heels though like i
was [ __ ] twerking dude just like that
yeah just pulling my ears and i was
there for like [ __ ] i don't know how
long and now this is both your identity
and passion who would have [ __ ]
thought that was your spider-man moment
dude that was one of the times i got my
[ __ ] so my mom made me do something
similar anytime i got in trouble uh in
vietnamese it was weight the way we
going all right it was what they would
call it
and you pretty much like go into the
corner and similar thing you go on your
knees and [ __ ] right so you have to be
like on your knees make sure you see it
off the butt
you have to be on your knees you cross
your arms you just stay there for
[ __ ] however long and i remember she
would make us do this for like at least
half an hour oh and if you got tired or
something that you like hella started
trying to sit down she can't slap you on
the [ __ ] head you like
and then one time i got a real choke
because i was like swearing
right so she didn't she didn't think it
was good enough to just make me get on
my knees she's like put me in the corner
at the dry cleaners maybe do that [ __ ]
and she's like
a dirty mouth so she took a [ __ ] uh a
chili pepper oh right she may bite it
she straight
i think she was just pissed how old were
you i was like probably like 10
11. so they just made you do jk party
challenges
basically y'all chinese parents are so
soft you guys are so ptsd so easy that
was one of the things but i got my eyes
beat for [ __ ] everything let me
finish my story maybe it's cool oh sorry
she makes me bite this [ __ ] thing
right i it's too spicy for me so i don't
know what to do but i'm also conflicted
because i think i can't leave but i
can't get water or anything like that so
i i don't know i'm so stupid i just
start [ __ ] drooling
and then because i have to be there for
like half an hour there's nothing to get
bored so i like don't mind just drooling
a big puddle i'm like kind of like
starting to get curious to see how big
this drawer
yeah is know what i mean i don't know
what else to do
the end of this like 20 30 minutes she
comes by this giant pile of drool on the
floor
she gets even more kissing me again
slaps me again then puts me into another
corner of the room makes me do it again
you can't win
i remember um
this didn't happen to me but this is
when i realized that parents are dumb
[ __ ] right
so like
it was it was we were at chuck e cheese
for my friend's birthday right and we're
having a nice [ __ ] chuck e cheese
birthday lunch eating a good cheese
pizza whatever is going on right
my friend starts crying and his mom is
like you and grateful son of a [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] she didn't say that but
basically the same sentiment it's your
birthday i got you chuck e cheese
whatever she starts beating his ass why
are you crying and then she keeps
[ __ ] them up asking him why he's
crying and i'm sitting there like lady
you're putting them in pain of course
he's gonna cry
duh you dumb [ __ ] right this is what
i'm thinking the whole time while i'm
like i hope she doesn't hit me because
i'm scared like that [ __ ] hand might
swing this way but i was like dude i was
like these parents are so dumb like this
is so obvious hitting a kid is gonna
make him cry
and i'm like dude this and then that's
when i was like this mom's [ __ ] nuts
i'm never going to his birthday party
ever again yeah police parents are crazy
too why do you pay to go to chuck e
cheese just to ruin everything and just
[ __ ] up their kids
chucky cheese what are you doing yeah
because you'd be wilding out dude yeah
even so that's all you're gonna do is
escalate the situation make it worse
like why did you financially invest in
this if you're gonna absolutely tank it
so smack up your kids and ask them why
they're crying while you're smacking
them
something that i really believe in that
happened in my neighborhood was it
wasn't just my mom and my dad raising us
like it was like the whole [ __ ]
neighborhood had to say like if we were
[ __ ] up in front of my neighbor's
house like my neighbor could come out
and discipline us no problem my mom's
gonna be like don't [ __ ] touch my
kids like that they're all like yo high
five [ __ ] yeah tell my kid what's up
like don't [ __ ] up but nowadays it's i
mean i'm doing it nowadays right but
all i all i hear about annie whom
is um parents telling people like don't
[ __ ] talk to my kid and all this [ __ ]
and i just think that i benefited a lot
from having other like no matter where i
went i had to be in check because it
wasn't just oh [ __ ] my mom's here it was
like oh [ __ ] adults are around bro is
that like do you feel like that was like
a like-minded community thing because
either way you were and or maybe even
like the like the ethnic group of your
community oh it was everybody it was i
mean i was in fairfax virginia it was
like you know one of my discipliners was
um this vietnamese lady named patty
so it's like you just don't know where
it's going to come from bro
no
i remember it was like that where like
uh
even like another parent that i didn't
really know down the street would like
yell at me or something and i'd go home
and tell my mom
and then my mom's like good
you know and then like now we're gonna
go and then we're gonna we're gonna take
you to go apologize yeah yeah like the
whole the what that's all i thought was
gonna play out completely backfired
we're gonna apologize to her and we're
gonna say i'm sorry and i'm i see my mom
thanking her for doing that i'm like
[ __ ] i had my ass whooped at
church and from my parents friends but
never like
the neighborhood yeah the neighborhood
there might be someone that's like a
karen or whatever like someone who's
tattling but then like man i think like
sometimes other parents will [ __ ] you up
harder than your own yeah dude my buddy
kyle kim's mom would [ __ ] come about
screaming
come screaming out of the house just
because i ddt her son in the [ __ ]
backyard
he didn't defend it you had no reversal
yeah come on what do you want me to do a
couple of us after church would go to my
mom's friend's house right and then so
she had this huge backyard because it
was like a three unit property with a
fat gate and they always took in the
dogs of people that moved away to japan
so they had like
[ __ ] tons of dogs and then so it was
like a good place to kind of just after
church everybody just go and play right
her husband was mean as [ __ ]
but taking too many dogs yeah well his
wife took it too
he was just a mean [ __ ] but also
a prankster right so like sometimes you
don't know if he's like [ __ ] with you
or sometimes he's just like
he's just disciplining you because he's
just [ __ ] mean but one time all of us
had the bright idea to get this shovel
and there's hella dog [ __ ] right so we
grabbed the dog [ __ ] and we started
launching it like this down the driveway
so we got the dog [ __ ] and then all of
us are just going because you know it
becomes like a [ __ ] catapult right so
we're just doing this [ __ ] [ __ ]
launching it right
and he comes out and we didn't know that
the [ __ ] was falling and like landing
all over the back of his
oh
car
good for the guy yeah dude so
the first thing first thing we feel is
this [ __ ] water just pouring behind
us we're like what the [ __ ] and then
straight with those he's spraying us
with a hose so we're all [ __ ] wet
running around like a bunch of [ __ ]
like ants trying to get away right
and then he goes come over here right
and then our parents start coming out
they're like what are you doing these
[ __ ] kids [ __ ] launching [ __ ] look
at the driver there's [ __ ] everywhere
dude dude he [ __ ] lined us up in a
[ __ ] line and started wailing on all
of our [ __ ] faces bam one by one so
we just had to stand there and all of
our parents were just like yelling at us
and they're like all right and then he's
like he's standing there and he goes bam
and then we're just like
yeah
and then later that we get to take a
shower and then clean up and then we're
like [ __ ] like you know after you
[ __ ] cry like a little [ __ ] you're
just tired as hell and we're just
sitting here eating noodles and [ __ ]
like looking at each other like we
[ __ ] up you guys didn't have to clean
it up i forgot man i had to clean it we
probably had to do some [ __ ] but at that
point it was so scary that [ __ ] was i
don't know but that we always did stupid
[ __ ] like that and get in trouble my
buddy derek took a bunch of it was
raining and he thought like it was
amazing that when we were pulling up
weeds like there was so much mud yeah he
was like what the [ __ ]
so then you then it's like well what are
we gonna do with it it's like well we
should probably we should probably start
smashing them on the the neighbor's
stairs
because that seems like a really fun
obviously
yeah and i wasn't even doing it that's
the thing that's [ __ ] up i was pulling
these [ __ ] up and just being like
whoa this one's even bigger than this
one
such kid's stupidest [ __ ] ever
and then he was taking like the pile of
them and he was like kept on whacking
them against his [ __ ] ladies
porch patty wong right so he's hitting
his mom's sports with his [ __ ] these
cloths of dirt and [ __ ] dunking on our
porch right because it would it would
explode
so you know he thought it was like
incredible and i was i just kept on
pulling these [ __ ] weeds up but i
thought i thought i was like damn this
is pretty this is pretty [ __ ] wild
um
so then patty we hear the screen door
open and we hear immediately like her
talking and like yelling at us and then
i was like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i was
like damn it she saw me we're [ __ ]
right and then she immediately just
walks right over to my mom like knocks
on the door tells her what happened and
then me and derek are out there if i can
clean it up we're [ __ ] cleaning up
her stare and that's what i learned
about this little thing called guilt by
association
my mom was like it doesn't matter that
you didn't do it stephen you were there
with derek and he was doing it and you
were watching so you were guilty just as
guilty as he is and i was like [ __ ]
this sucks but this is black this is
whack this is not justice that shaped my
political opinions for years to come
one of the hardest times my mom beat my
[ __ ] ass
it's similar to the other marg great
story
it's very similar but i forgot about it
because it's like
it's actually kind of worse
so my grandpa lived in the back house
and my mom would always make me like go
do errands for them and [ __ ] like just
go do stuff for him i was probably in
like fifth grade or so and obviously in
my head i'm a [ __ ] genius dude like
i'm the smartest [ __ ] kid there ever
was my mom was asking me like go over
there and like drop something off or go
talk to your grandpa and then come back
i forgot what the errand was but at the
time i was like dude i don't want to
[ __ ] do this [ __ ] and i was like mad
at my mom for making me go do this
so i go over there i come back and she
goes hey so what did what did your
grandpa say
and then in my head i had this [ __ ]
brilliant idea of like oh yeah i'ma
[ __ ] get you back lady so i come back
and i'm like oh yeah i don't know it was
weird like
like grandpa said you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and she goes
what
my grandpa don't speak english that way
it's weird
yeah grandpa's being weird
like in my head i was a [ __ ] genius
dude i was like yeah you say you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like i don't know like
she goes oh he said that and i was like
yeah it's crazy and i was like yeah she
was like yeah that is weird that he said
she's not laughing she's playing she's
playing around and i was like eat my
[ __ ] ass bro
and just and just yeah bro it was
[ __ ] terrible
it was [ __ ] terrible like
like with your hands or with like a shoe
a slipper she would she would grab
anything like i remember one of the
hottest things that she would beat me
with
was like the hot wheel tracks oh she was
like smack those have got some flex to
them yeah bro and it's like a little
i remember i had this sick ass little
[ __ ] power ranger tent right and it
was like they did these little small
rods
and she was just [ __ ] whacking me
with those like crazy bro one of the
worst things i hate hated getting uh
beat with was uh so in fifth grade i was
like in like the
marching band right and then i think i
was like
in sixth then in sixth grade my mom
found out that what i really wanted to
play with saxophone
and then those things are expensive it's
like i don't know 900 bucks or a
thousand bucks so my mom's okay we'll
start renting and if you really like it
we'll we'll stick with it
and uh the minute i opened the case at
home
and she saw the saxophone cleaner
i don't know why she's like
i'm taking it and then she has a this
little thing full of like her weapons to
beat me with and the saxophone cleaner
was wonderful she just knew that she
stole this saxophone cleaner i saw it
and she just knew she was like i'm
taking this so it's her feather duster a
rice paddle and then now her saxophone
cleaner and then when she hit me with
that thing because there's like a little
handle at the end it also kind of bends
a little bit you know like the saxophone
goes like this so you gotta be able to
like you know do that kind of thing
like she would take it and the the flex
on that thing would [ __ ] go with the
flex dude it was her snap so bad
why did i want to pick them
what the [ __ ] i love how she ruined
something that you were like genuinely
into just by like taking ooh it's gonna
be a good weapon i [ __ ] hated the
feather duster that was the worst one
she pulled the feather duster out i knew
my entire she flips it around the other
way right yeah she grabs it by the face
so she's got a grip on it she's all soft
for her it's all like [ __ ]
moisturizing
yeah she gives you it's got like tape on
the other end for no [ __ ] reason and
just whips you well sometimes i'll get
into trouble or i know some shit's gonna
happen and i get home before she does
[ __ ] i hide everything right she goes
right to her little basket and she goes
where is that
armory
[ __ ] grandpa was acting weird today
yeah
nick's grandpa came over took us it
you're a [ __ ] i don't know what the
[ __ ] came over me too like i remember i
just thought you're on one bro yeah i
was alone your parents ever played like
mind games with you and like kind of
[ __ ] with you i'm not that [ __ ] man i
think i repressed a lot of these
memories you know what uh my parents did
that i thought was like looking back now
like you sons of [ __ ] right they used
to [ __ ] um
tell me like you know we're not as bad
as other parents you're lucky you got us
and i'm like why i'm like why he goes
you know other parents hit their kids
with objects you see we only use our
hands
it's not as basic and i'm not like
[ __ ] dad you you have a full
[ __ ] closed fist when you hit me
that's a man's head dude you got to hit
me with a slap sometimes they don't have
to [ __ ] touch you right so like my uh
mind games do this one yeah my games are
crazy my neighbor zack he
his mom was a disciplinarian bro she was
like this woman from georgia and she did
not [ __ ] around at all like if you just
like you know didn't wear your shoes in
the house for too long or whatever i got
on the carpet
right so i was just sick of it every
time i go over there this chick is gonna
give me some [ __ ] right she was a sweet
lady
when she was sweet she was like two
designers halloween costumes and stuff
she was like amazing but if you [ __ ]
with her she's going to step right so um
one time like it was like late at night
or some [ __ ] and i was i was telling
zach i was like yo dude i think i hate
your mom man
you got a sleepover you're like can i
tell you something true i hate your
straight up i just hate your mom
i hate her [ __ ] hate your mother and
he's like dude i hate her too so no he
he well yeah he was you know venting and
[ __ ] but then i think he felt guilty
probably the next day so guess what he
does who tells your mom
he calls my he tells his mom his mom
calls my mom then i have to go over
there what a rat and his mom is at the
door
and she's like got tears in her eyes you
thought you're going to get in trouble
like you hate me stephen paul and i was
like
that was enough for me to just like oh
god bro like broken every i was just
like oh and i started meeting just
crying and crying oh
no
why is she looking at for validation
from a child anyway well it's probably
the price probably that this nice lady
spent all this time like investing into
these other kids or like i want to be
nice to them like i'm making costumes
and stuff and you know if they [ __ ]
my carpet i'm like mean to them but
that's discipline and then he's like you
hate me well when you're a kid you're
just a little [ __ ] too you're just
like yeah i hate you right now she
shouldn't listen to comments is what i'm
saying
don't look at you know you don't need
validation from a child bro
my mom was uh really creative so like
when i was in fifth grade i already got
kicked out of two elementary schools so
i think my mom's kind of like what the
[ __ ] going on with this regretful
about life yeah she's probably like i
need to get a refund on this
[ __ ] and in fifth grade we had
like these this aquarium with like two
pet turtles and i think my adhd was just
crazy because it's like i'll literally
just blink
and then the next thing i know my hands
in the aquarium like playing with it and
then my teacher is like bar i'm like it
almost like snaps me out of it like
oh [ __ ] like let go of the turtle and
then go back to my chair so like every
time like my i got sent to the office or
something whatever happened you blacked
out and i would black out and my the my
mom would ask me what the [ __ ] going
on why are you just getting all this
trouble like man i don't even know i was
just hiding playing hide and seek in
class by myself and then um so my mom
actually did she was like this is what i
want i need to know like every single
hour of the day
if you're [ __ ] up or not so she came
over to uh
uh
my my classroom during like a parent
teacher conference and my table was the
only table that had this index card
taped to it
and it had like
like uh like nine to ten ten to eleven
eleven to twelve whatever right and my
mom gave the teacher the policy of every
hour if i'm good she puts a star on
so that way she can pinpoint exactly
like what hour or whatever that i was
like [ __ ] what are you gonna do with
that information like two to three i
need to show up and thank you yeah yeah
like she'll show up she'll show up or
figure out what the [ __ ] is going on
like bart had applesauce now we know if
he gets sugar he's all applesauce is a
trigger because like in fourth grade i
was like taking my uh
best friend's pet cat to school
against his will so i just do a lot
against his will well he had this new
kitten at home and i was like this is a
whole other video watch though this
guy's super cute this is fast he's like
a super cute cat and i was like yo
marquis says we should bring him to
school and he goes nah we can't bring
back to school i'm like oh you're right
so he went to go take a shower do it so
i took the pet cat i put my backpack so
i took it to school and then i took him
out then i put him in my drawer and then
he sat behind me and i was like he's
checking out he's like that's my cat
the kids like started meowing you know
and the teacher's like is there a cat
you brought a [ __ ] cat to school
cause it wasn't even your [ __ ] it
wasn't even my cat
you're such a menace
bro just when i thought like you would
run out of stories you never run out of
[ __ ] stores when you were beat by a
saxophone cleaner bro have you guys ever
been uh jumped by your parents before
no in what way
[ __ ] tag team your ass double team
dude so like like one whoops you then
goes the other one [ __ ] high fives
i [ __ ] deserve this one though
because we had guests over right and i
um it was like my parents friends from
church and all this stuff and then like
um every every sunday night i get to
play video games
so i was like mom like can i go play
games she goes no like when guests are
over like we have to like give them
attention that's like the right thing to
do and i'm like all right and then this
is evil kid joe right i'm like well if
they're gone guess what i could play my
game
so i went out there and walked
chilling in the living room right i was
like
you know what's funny uh mom was saying
like you guys are overstaying your
welcome
holy [ __ ]
and i in my head i'm like
genius yeah they're gonna leave
i could play my [ __ ] games
third grade or some [ __ ] right i was a
child you're a [ __ ] genius like nine
or something right yeah so i'm sitting
there
chaos in ensues right she my parents are
denying no no we didn't i was like yeah
you did you said it back
double down
the look on the guy's face he's just
like oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] and then like
i'm like here we go sega genesis you're
already starting it up all right i'm
just like
sega genesis
here we go
my parents are uncoiling the controller
my parents are [ __ ] like they're like
trying to get them to stay at home i'm
laughing right
and then because they're gonna [ __ ] me
up in front of them right and i didn't
even know that was coming because my
dumb ass was just like oh if they leave
then i play my games right so so when
they're saying bye i'm standing there at
the door saying bye with my parents
right thanks for not overstaying i'm
like bye it was fun having you come back
next week i think i'm gonna play sonic
and knuckles no i'll play sonic 3. as
soon as the door closes i do one of
these things because they grab the back
of my shirt i get [ __ ] up so hard i
get away i [ __ ] go to the uh backyard
and [ __ ] i'm crying my eyes out because
i didn't even that blind side to me
i was like i didn't even expect i was
gonna get [ __ ] up i don't know why i'm
getting [ __ ] up
and i don't know why i don't know why
i'm getting [ __ ] up right they chased
me around the house and then like
also i had that audacity to say while
i'm crying in the bed they put me in bed
they said you got to go to sleep now and
i'm like but i don't get to play video
games
you said when they left i could play
video i don't know i was like i was
waiting for that that's how that's and
then they get you by just like and
you'll never play video games ever oh
now they still let me push off to sleep
that's [ __ ] hilarious hey real quick
real quick honestly worth it uh so
really glad that jarelyn told me that
because like because we actually had a
little moment at the door and like like
and i love you was was was given instead
and i'm not kidding this sounds like
[ __ ] crazy but she died a year later
in a in a car accident like
and she got to say you got to yeah every
time i think about her
i always think about her crying and
telling me you hate me stephen paul and
like you know it's like oh man this is
hard right but then i remembered that
wow that because she confronted me as a
child and she told me that we had that
little i love you and i always think
about that so that's a huge learning
like experience for for a kid too yeah
yeah
that's true because no asian pear would
have said they they loved you or hated
you they just [ __ ] you up but it's a
it's a nice thing to think about like
the way that we get disciplined and uh
and the good that can come from it yeah
i don't know what happened in my
situation but i'm glad for you though
i have no silver line did you ever play
sega genesis again hell yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you